Well meet Kate, I know
you know Dr. Goodall.
Y'all have met obviously, right?
- We met, yes.
- I was gonna say that would
be weird at this point.
So I heard that you just turned 11, right?
- [Ava] Yes.
- Happy Birthday.
- Thank you.
- [Kelly] That's so exciting.
What'd you do? Have a party?
- Yeah, I hung out with
my friends and family
and I love all the presents I got.
- [Kelly] Awesome.
- I got a big Squish
Mellow. I really love that.
- [Kelly] Oh my God, my daughter
is obsessed with Squish Mellows.
- Yeah.
- And I went to my favorite
place ever, Canada's Wonderland.
It's an amusement park.
And I love roller coasters so much-
- [Kelly] Me too.
- so that was really fun.
- Do you like when your stomach
gets taken away from you?
- [Ava] Yeah.
- Me too.
It changes a little as you get older.
You're like, huh, I can't do the ride
over and over again anymore.
I could do it once, but it's really fun.
So you got to travel around the world
when you were working on the show Jane.
So did you have a favorite?
- Yes. I went to Kenya,
which is my favorite.
- [Kelly] Beautiful.
- And I really loved
it because I got to see
a lion family and they had
two little cubs that were
actually eating the insides of a zebra.
So I thought that was amazing.
- [Kelly] Were you scared at all?
'Cause they get really close.
- No, I wasn't scared.
- [Kelly] Love it.
- I just love them.
- Yeah, me too, so pretty and beautiful.
So Dr. Jane, how much
joy does it bring you
to see kids like Ava
Louise inspired by animals?
- Well, I want all, everybody
inspired, not just kids.
- [Kelly] Yeah, absolutely.
- Everybody should understand
that animals have feelings
emotions, personalities and intelligence.
You know that, don't you?
- Yeah.
- And are affected by what we do.
- Absolutely.
- [Kelly] Yeah, absolutely.
- Well, we're destroying them.
And so that's why a show
like this is so important
because it'll help other children
to realize animals need help, right?
- Absolutely. Well Kate,
what animals have fascinated
your kids the most?
Like which ones do they
go nuts anywhere they are?
I bet chimpanzees at this point.
- Yes. They know 'cause of my obsession.
That sort of has forced
them to be obsessed.
But my husband has this thing about
naming each of us as an animal.
So he thinks that I'm a snow fox.
- [Kelly] Oh.
- For whatever reason-
- You a little sneaky?
- and the big, Oh, is
that why he thinks that?
- I don't know, are you sneaky?
You're sly.
- I'll never say.
- [Kelly] Okay, okay.
- So yeah, we like foxes
in our family a lot.
- [Kelly] Okay.
- I always Red admiral in my group.
We all had to choose our animal names and
as I was the oldest, I was,
admiral was what attracted me.
Red Admiral Butterfly.
- I love it.
- I love it. So, Dr.
Jane, could you tell us
a little about the new show, Jane?
- Well, I think this Jane can tell more
about the show than I can.
but basically, in the
show, I'm your hero, right?
- [Ava] Yes.
- In the show, probably not
really, but in the show.
So you have a room and it's
got all sorts of decorations
of pictures of Jane and
David Graybeard and-
- [Ava] Yes.
- everything. And so, yeah.
- Oh, so she's your inspiration
that puts you on a course-
- [Ava] Yeah.
- Right? That's amazing.
What all do you get to do in the show?
Like where do you go? What do you do?
Do you become a bee? Is
that what I'm seeing?
- So Jane basically goes
on like imaginary missions
with her best friend David
and her toy chimpanzee, Graybeard,
which comes to life.
And basically she does different things
like she rides on bees
and on those missions,
she finds lots of cool animal facts
and how to save the animal.
- And I'm assuming pollen
and how we need bees.
- Yeah.
- All of that kind of stuff.
I love that.
Like I love watching,
I love when people come
out with shows where parents can sit
with them and we enjoy it as much
as our kids do and we enjoy
like learning with them.
'Cause some of the things you
learn when you're in school
and then you forget when
you're older and you're like
I remember that from
like sixth grade science.
And you're like, wait
I'm not smarter than a
fifth grader apparently.
But Dr. Jane, what's the
most important message
that you wanna share with
people about our world?
What do you think the
most important thing is?
- I think the most important
thing is to remember
that every day we live on
this planet, we make an impact
and we get to choose what
sort of impact we make.
But in order to be able to choose
we have to alleviate poverty,
because if you are really poor
you can't choose as we all can.
You know, don't buy that
because it was bad for the environment
or cruel to animals or cheap
because of unfair wages.
That's really important, isn't it?
- Yes.
- Everything is connected.
Well let's do a quick
commercial break everybody.
Y'all be sure to watch Jane.
You can find it on Apple TV+.